greetings it's Tuesday the 19th Uncle
Joey here ready for Freddy the checkin
is brought to you by liquid IV I know
you Savages are out there parting like
unbelievable when you need to recover
fast turn to liquid IV listen you're
jumping up and down it's Christmas
you're drinking eggnog with Dinka juice
in it you got this you got this you need
to stay hydrated liquid IV gets you
hydrated to times faster than water
alone and it even comes and is
sugar-free let me tell you something
they launched three new flavors the
white peach tremendous the green grape
out of this world the lemon lime it's
like Gatorade and heat and all three of
them will set you on fire after a long
night of jumping up and down and doing
other things you know what I'm saying
I've been there but I'm not there
anymore now I drink liquid IV keeps me
alive in the morning you understand me
after a cup of coffee I drink a little
liquid IV a white peach I put that thing
in it to help me out and boom no gluten
soy dairy or GMOs and no artificial
sweeteners either I don't even know what
GMOs are sugar is replaced with an amino
acid alose blend which has the same
taste and texture of table sugar it's
tremendous try the white peach it'll put
you in a different dimension you
understand me grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier in bulk nationwide
at Costco tremendous they got a bunch of
flavors they even got combo packs now so
you can try a bunch of different combo
packs or get 20% off when you go direct
to liquid
i.com use code Joey listen Uncle Joey is
going to save you 20% start the 2024
with liquid IV you're going to love it
I'm going to give you 20% off anything
you order when you shop for better
hydration today using promo code Joey J
o e y liquid
i.com that's liquid
i.com the checkin is also brought to you
by Factor listen if you're trying to eat
better in 2024 make it easy on yourself
with factor factor is America's number
one ready to eat meal delivery service
that sends Chef prepared dietician
approved meals right to your door they
take 2 minutes to prepare to prepare you
just heat them up in the microwave on a
skillet and you're all set Tip Top mooo
no waiting in line the grocery store no
chopping prepping or cleaning up just an
awesome meal right there when you want
them the thing I like about this most is
listen half of us are on the go we're
trying to eat healthy this is where
Factor comes in they got 35 meal options
to choose from every week so you'll have
much more variety they come vegan
vegetarian and Protein Plus calorie
smart meals and you'll never skimp on
Flavor right now head toctor meals.com
D50 that's D50 go to factor meals.com
and pressing code Diaz 50 you ready for
this I'm Gonna Get You 50% off who's
better than Factor meals nobody that's
diaz5 at Factor meals.com
diaz5 Z to get your 50% off all right
let's get this party started turn off
your TVs run for your lives it's over
they didn't put you on this planet just
to give up if Uncle Joey could do it I
rule the world actually you got to be
thinking welcome back
[Music]
to
the lighting looks different it looks
like a greenish and a blue today you
know how we do it dog we're trying to
diversify over here you know what I'm
saying how is your day
tan it was fine you know I'm
[__] it's a big difference like you
talked about you would talk about going
from you know being on the road to being
at the store and the stuff dying for me
it's I'm having the most fun the weekend
like it's it couldn't be more fun doing
two shows a night and then I go back to
like day job on Monday like oh it's it's
very different very
[__] yeah doing comedy the whole time
you're thinking about quitting your [__]
like why am I gonna go back on
Monday it's the it's like a surreal
world that you live in when you're like
a in between because you can't really
quit your day job to MC
right so but once you start featuring
you gotta [__] or get off the [__]
pot yeah you have to decide about the
job and that's when you look at your
budget you look at what's coming in what
you're expected to come in what's in
your bank account you know do I need a
[__] Corvette not really I just need
a Nissan I could sell down you
know when I started com like when I got
serious about
comedy I I had nothing I was coming off
a divorce I was
I was basically [__] living from day
to day but I knew that like I had to
have my apartment went from like $980 to
$400 like everything got cut you know
the phone you don't need it a cable TV
you don't need it when you're doing
comedy you just don't need these
things and that's what forces you it's
like to get good at comedy for like two
or three years to get into the Rhythm
you have to force yourself it's like a
prison you go to work you go home you
eat you write you go to the gym then you
go do two open mics and then you go home
and then on the weekends you know you
[__] work till Friday and then you
and it's hard it's [__] hard man it's
hard to balance both and at one point
you're gonna bust and one day you just
walk out of the
office I wouldn't be surpris it's just
and it's not like I actually my day job
is not bad but it's
especially weekends that where stuff
goes well and like the shows are
fun and then like you know being I've
always the the road has is always like
so romantic to me like just the idea of
like being in a hotel in a city like
I've never been to it's just like I
don't it just sounds awesome so it's
just like the entire thing is
fun like I to me that was the allore of
it I I like to travel I like
the but it was weird going back into
like for me I have to remember I took a
job and I was selling cars and he he
took the he made the job flexible enough
you know and it was working I wasn't I
wasn't becoming rich but as I I was at
least you know keeping the lights on but
then things would happen to tell me this
isn't what I'm going to do anymore like
I get a sign from God or whoever the
[__] it was the comedy Gods like you
know I would always have like the last
two salesman jobs I had the cars blew
up you know like when you were driving
them yeah like I went to do comedy and I
kept a job and they would give me a car
to drive and one time I just left the
car one time I got stuck in a brand
spanking new and it was for Bert's
manager Judy Brown Bert Sebastian's
manager right she had a gig like like at
a a ski
resort and it didn't have a hotel the
feature in the headliner had a hotel but
I didn't get a hotel so I basically
drove up there for the small 30 whatever
the [__] it
is and
uh my [__] at the end of the show I
was having a good time and I got my car
was one of those brand new
jeeps like uh it was a I mean brand
spanking knew it had to be 90 four Jeep
and the [__] timing belt or something
blew out on it Jesus that I I I I asked
I was talking to Josh about that this
weekend about like if your car breaks
down on the way to like it just I get
anxiety about stuff like that now get
into an accident it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen you know and then one night
was the time I told you I went up to
like Wyoming and the guy had to leave
because his wife was cheating on him and
on the way back the car started going on
fire the car just lit itself on fire dog
on the road it was [__] snowing we
had to walk like a mile in the snow with
our little bags overnight bags I never
heard those people again like that car
just blew up on i70s somewhere and I
never heard from those people again it
was just it was and I and I would go
home and go I wouldn't even be upset I
just knew it was a sign telling me to go
for it and I wouldn't go for it I was
such a [__] [__] like I always
wanted that well I had child support I
had you know I had a bunch of [__]
things had an addiction I had child
support it wasn't like I was putting it
into my house like painting the room or
nothing I had an apartment I never
turned the stove on I ate all my three
meals
out and I snorted coke and I [__] PID
child support that's what I was goingon
to ask like because you're a very
organized person I can imagine you
writing a budget with Coke did you ever
like budget Coke into your like expenses
in those days hell yeah I had a I had a
monthly stiping for it because why lie
to
yourself right I wasn't gonna lie to
myself I was putting away like anywhere
from 150 to 300 a week in those days and
I was
broke and I was [__]
broke just you know selling Coke selling
an ounce of weed I'm just putting it all
together while I'm doing comedy bro in
the beginning in La I think till 2002 in
La I was doing creepy [__] you know and
now here I was at The Comedy Store I was
selling pounds of weed to agents and you
know so you gotta do what you got to do
especially like even back then it
probably wasn't a lot of money but
features make at most usually unless the
headline is very nice like a hundred
bucks a show yeah so if you got five
shows and no hotel is a feature which is
the status quo now right yeah they don't
want [__] hotel now you know it's
it's you break even so you need another
job it's uh it it's very scary to think
about doing it so but like that's
because I I've been thinking about you I
think about like the stuff we talked
about on the church a lot and something
I forget who it was I also I was
listening to another podcast and the
podcaster was talking a comic was
talking about like do doing a vision
board on like New Year's Eve so like
I've been try I've been working on
something like that like a plan and like
do you believe in any of that stuff or
not really because you take a plan very
seriously I know
that of what like uh I'm sorry I just
got there my oh no that's
okay and I couldn't the the message
wouldn't come up on my [__] phone and
I knew he was going to hit me back
so but anyway I'm very sorry vision
board no just just like a plan for like
the next year so like I have a plan you
have to have a yearly plan a six-month
plan and a three Monon plan and a 30-day
plan and that was me you know that was
what I did you
know people I just saw Sebastian the
other day on the podcast talking about
how he never wrote his goals down and
he's one of the biggest stars in comedy
so who the [__] gives the [__] what I
think what I'm saying is everybody's
different everybody reacts to different
things I wanted
to see my efforts I wanted to make
sure that 15 sets was
done like you could do whatever you want
Joey you could do whatever you want you
could snore Coke you could stay out but
you got to give me 15 sets a month and
then the numbers became Higher and
Higher and then
it got to 30 35 sets a month you
know yeah and I think I'm sure like I I
don't do it and I'm sure there's a lot
of comics who don't do it
but if it it obviously worked for you so
that's why like I'm trying that's why I
like listening to comedians podcast
because I I I try to get little things
of what they do and especially the ones
who have successful podcasts are doing
something right you sat there with me
for years
listening to other Comics fears their
goals how they did certain things
whether it was writing every comic
brought something different to the table
every musician that we had brought
something different to the table I gotta
be honest with you the guy I learned the
most from in all the years of podcasting
was Rudy Saro and I still confer with
Rudy for big
decisions how's Rudy because huh Rudy's
[__] great I talk to Rudy once a week
though that's my
brother that's crazy and he's still I
see I see him on Instagram and Twitter
all the time so what is I'm sorry for
interrupting what was he why do you take
so much from him Rudy gave us something
on every episode and whether people took
it or not I loved when people would hit
me up and go why do you put Rudy on
there for and I didn't give a [__] Rudy
always has a place to speak with me
because he's not just a bass player he's
an artist and he's got 50 years in so
whatever stupid story you got don't
match up to him you know he woke up on a
bus one day a plane went down it was his
[__] best friend you know on a
[__]
tour what do you do on a Saturday night
whatever I don't know if it was a
Saturday when he died Randy rhod but not
to he taught me the the most important
thing I ever learned from anybody in
comedy
he taught me the words labor of
love and that changed my whole career
that changed everything for me when I
heard those words and days later when it
sank
in what we do is a labor of
love they pay us for
traveling they pay us to have to deal
with [__] people talking to you in
your
ear I want to go to Monaco with you
whatever the [__] they're saying that's
what you're getting paid for when you're
performing whether it's a violin whether
it's a harmonica whether it's comedy
whether it's spoken word it's a labor of
love you're giving yourself away a piece
of yourself away if you're not doing it
for the labor of
love go [__] do something
different go do something different and
that's how my life was when I first got
into comedy it was all a labor love I
didn't give a [__] about what you were
paying me oh you going to pay me 50
bucks perfect I can eat you
know and and then it became something
else and then it became a
financial and then I didn't like it
anymore because that's why I enjoyed the
book signing so
much there was no money they had to buy
a book for 20 bucks you know they're
going to get it anyway on Audible or
whatever I didn't want to charge you to
take a picture or to [__] shake my
hand you know I didn't want to charge
you 20 bucks to the book signing I
wanted to be there and if you noticed I
was on time to all of them I brought
joints for everybody on all of them I
wanted that was a labor love for me
there was no money involved listen I'm
I'm I'm not in the mood of taking a
microphone tonight and I'm not in the
mood to answer questions but I got two
or three minutes for you I wanted to
talk to them because when I did stand up
it was just a stupid [__] picture
that's not really uh contact
point I learned a lot from those [__]
book signings I learned a lot about
myself now I gotta see if it over to
other
things what did you learn about yourself
at the book
signing that I really love people again
and that doing standup and that higher
level pushed me away from these people
that that's not what I ever wanted to do
that's why I didn't I never saw myself
in an arena or a stadium I never saw
those things one of the one of the
greatest memories I remember hearing is
that Gabriel did like three shows on
Christmas night Christmas Eve at the at
John lovit comedy
club and I heard that the last show he
took them all to [__]
pancakes he [__] Denny's yeah yeah
yeah you heard the story yeah you know
that's something that [__] last
forever that's something that I wish you
know and every time I had an opportunity
to do it like during the pandemic it it
fell apart on me whether it was getting
the movie theater to show the [__]
many Saints in Newark the patreon people
which I'm happy you know now looking
[Laughter]
back
but it taught me that again that's why I
just I didn't want like when I did that
last show in New York in January with
you right I knew I didn't want to get on
stage a long
time I knew it that night like I'm
[__] getting out of here and it
wasn't a Sony Hall I love Sony Hall I
love was it was I just did not want to
do it
anymore and until I fall in love with it
again I won't I'm not I love doing this
thing with you on Monday nights it's no
pressure I don't give a [__] if we're on
the Apple top 100 I don't care if iTunes
don't like it I don't give a [__] if
YouTube don't like it guess what the
only one that's got to like it is us so
in my world that's call a labor of
[__] love if I'm out here taking
pictures all day and making videos to
watch the podcast that's one thing I
enjoy doing the DraftKings things I
really do doing the videos you know I
like doing stupid [__] video whatever
the I'm limited with those and that's
that doesn't make me happy but but back
to the what we were talking about
Rudy taught me you know I learned from
Ralphie on there I learned from Theo Von
on there I got a bunch of lessons from
those things where you looked at people
and you're like really you did that that
was very interesting to me back then you
know when we were doing the podcast 2015
16 it was really great you know was a
[__] bad for me and you because we
were destroying our
bodies we had F I mean we had a blast
but it's yeah just the knowledge like
that's one one of the reasons I love
podcast it was a labor love we were
doing it with no rule
book that's why for you to look at a
podcast now that somebody did take for
you to look at a podcast of somebody who
had the balls to do a podcast 13 12 10
years ago and say well on that podcast
you said something wrong I want you to
remember one thing there was no rule
book
there was no rule book on YouTube there
was no [__] rule
book so and it it's something that that
I think it's talked about a lot and it's
it's the people who came to watch didn't
have a like it's people might look back
at it who weren't church fans or that
wasn't for them and they might get
upset but it's not like it's not like we
got a bunch of hate back then no there
was no rules right ay Church nobody
nobody takes Bard and does a [__]
podcast for four hours all right on a
Sunday night with [__] people calling
in and Duncan sending pictures of dirty
people and you know no there was no
rules and it yes it was a labor love I
think for like a year I was getting
robbed on the ads because I didn't know
how to read the ads so I would just read
them every show and they were only
paying me for one read oh and they're
like your sponsors love you yeah because
I read them every [__] show for free
that was like a year I didn't know what
I was doing I was a [__] idiot but
that's crazy it was a labor of love it
gave us a window like now to just
connect [__] around and if you're in
you're in if you're not take a chance
Columbus did take a [__] shuttle I
was thinking about about that time today
because it I don't remember the exact
day I don't know if you I wonder if you
do but it's around now that you recorded
it's either you or the
priest it's right it was right before
Christmas yeah right we released in
January yeah cuz remember 10 years ago
11 yeah might even be more than that
2012 it's about yeah I was thinking
about before I was watching the [__]
news
before this afternoon it was raining
terribly I made a video of me and gray
eating a piece of cat Pizza I saw that
dog she teares Pizza [__] up first
off gray tears anything
up the only thing gray really don't like
is shrimp and she's a [__] cat and
she make sense she doesn't like all the
fishes but gray will eat pork fried rice
gray will eat
[__] sesan beef gray will eat [__]
cheeseburgers if you leave gray alone
for two minutes and walk away from your
dish she will jump on that table and at
least try your [__] you got I get mad at
her but I
don't do do you do you put it like on a
separate plate for her or you or you
just know that she's gonna go after
your I first of all I know she likes
salami right she loves
Puda she loves wet
muts like you know she loves [__]
ham won't eat
cheese but B's head Deluxe ham she will
tear that up to shreds okay and I love
her to death but that cat eats
everything remember I picked that cat up
on the streets and she wasn't feral she
was half feral and [__] you know she
was living in somebody's house but they
got dogs and she couldn't go back into
the house so she had to live outside
when I met that cat that cat was about
three and I was amazed that that's the
longevity of a cat who lives outside
it's 3
years I befriended her outside in the
street she walked me
home and I played with her outside and I
had treats from my cats so I brought
them down for her and one day she just
scratched the [__] door and my cats
went
crazy and you know the labor the owner
of the cat told me she goes I got to be
honest with you you should just take her
because she's your [__] cat you're
her dad I could see it she [__]
follows you and we brought her even back
here I mean she's been with us now for
yeah 11
years but the last two years she's
really come out of her [__]
shell that's great when I wake up she
follows me down here and she jumps on my
lap while I'm on the computer well you
had to keep her separated right like you
had to keep her like in your room or
something no she didn't like anybody
else when we first got her she was like
[__] you [__] I don't like you
[__] at all
[Laughter]
okay
and she lived in a house with like seven
cats that [__] hated her and she
would walk to the kitchen in front of
them and they would go like what the
[__] is that look at it she would walk
real timid and eat her food and then
walk right back to her little hiding
spot always facing them so they couldn't
attack her from the back she always laid
the wall she was very smart and she got
into a couple beefs with like two of the
cats the girls [__] hated
her there was one there was one girl I
had that I gotta tell you broke her
heart she didn't last long after that
she did not like her in the
house just the fact that she was there
she didn't like it nope wow did not
[__] like it but ever since we moved
to
Jersey when we first moved me and her
got into a beef one day
and we didn't [__] hang out for like
three
months over what how do you get in to
beef for the cat I don't know I went
upstairs one day I laid on the bed she
didn't like it or something and she
scratched me so I pushed her away and
then she bit my finger something it was
something like what the [__] BR but we
had just moved here she was in Shell
Shar she was like a Vietnam vet so you
know she's sleeping on my bed I can't
see at night I got no [__] carrots I
walked back to the bed to and I think
it's my sleep atum machine so when I put
my hand out I I pushed her and she
[__] swatted at me and I'm like great
what the [__] and then so we didn't talk
for like three or four months then
[__] it took me a year to get back in
the good graces but I'm I got farther
with her in that year than I did in like
eight or nine
years W she sleeps with me she sleeps in
between me and my wife you know she
[__] once we go for break once I get
coffee in the morning she sleeps on top
of the heater for a few hours and once I
come to the office she comes right down
here and she's by my feet meowing pering
and then I'll leave for the day and now
she actually Waits me by the garage and
if I smoke dope in the garage she
follows me outside to the garage it's a
trip that's awesome that's crazy it's a
trip man especially so many years so you
guys were eating pizza and watching the
news you were saying so I came home
today I had to go to the doctor ATT 10 I
went to the gym for a little while and I
had like a half hour break and I was
sitting down here my wife came down with
two slices of pizza and she goes did you
eat lunch when you were out and I go no
I'll take a slice I mean I'm not I don't
feel like going to a restaurant or
anything but I did see something when I
went upstairs to go to the bathroom the
pizza case was upside down by the door
we were going to take it out wherever
goes out next take the garbage
out and she was already sniffing at the
pizza box so she knew it was she's
[__] smart man so as soon as my wife
came down she came down after my wife my
wife goes go to the back I have to go
upstairs and get get something to drink
in that time she jumped on the [__]
chair with me and just started chopping
I'm there was a pizza cheese sticking
out of the side and you know crispy
pizza and [__] Oldbridge is back they
opened up after the fire I didn't know I
went up to Jiu-Jitsu last week and I Saw
the Sign so when I went Sunday on the
way back I called my wife and there was
some kids here and I go you know what
I'll bring a pie for them I didn't even
eat the pizza but when I opened it up it
was cheesy nice like it was just an
extra cheese pie crispy to the max like
only they could do and [__] uh I
didn't eat that day so my wife brought
down the slice I give me a slice I
didn't eat that whole slice Mercy
[__] gray ate the whole slice to give
her half the [__] cheese I got like
the crust and a little bit of the middle
that's [__] up she eats that much then
she eats a can of cat food she eats a
can of cat food at night and She'll
follow me around throughout the goddamn
day the cats are interesting animal
listen animals are interesting I'm
thinking of getting a dog next if you
look at what you do when you turn 60
what to do when you turn 60 to P to get
a dog that's awesome another German
Shepherd yeah but then I got to walk it
I got to figure out my leg situation and
my knee situation I don't want to walk a
German shepper on [__] roller skates
or a skateboard or I gotta tie him to my
[__] stroller like a fat [__] old
[__] and he pushes me like mush you know
I don't need that
either what are you g to do you know
what I'm saying I want to know the
people who donated to Black lives matter
why because I need a big I need a big
envelope I don't want to work no
[Laughter]
more you we could start you a GoFundMe
no I don't want to GoFundMe why like
Cuban lives
matter yeah but how you gonna get the
word out look if if I can't get the word
out you ain't gonna get it out you know
what I'm saying I got connections I
could spread the word we'll buy wraps
and little boat for Cuban people and
bring them here and give them more
dignity but I'm not looking to bring buy
wraps I'm looking to [__] score 10
million first then I'll buy a raap they
get a rap I knock down my 10 million
because I was thinking about me and my
wife were talking about look at all
those people who donate the black lives
matters those people just broke off
bought houses and really didn't do
anything with the money in my world it
it seemed like it was a total
scam and it was I did see that like
there were some people who [__] off
with the money oh please they always do
even when the Hurricane Katrina that may
is doing 10 to 20 and aransa right now
he's doing [__] he's he's helping the
Girl Scout make cookies oh 10 to
20 so so that so that's your your new
plan Cuban lives matter what's that
Cuban lives matter sure why not
everybody should do it I'm gonna get
like a Chinese guy I'm gonna find the
guy from Portugal I'm gonna find a
couple [__] zomia everybody matters
now send the check
[__] guilt on their face that's
what it was a perfect scam they bounced
off in guilt I guarantee 90% of the
people who donated to that were white
Americans and like 50 had money and they
felt guilty my grandfather owned a slave
cut a check now the guilt is over
instead of going out and shaking one's
hand and inviting them over to your
house you know what I'm saying cutting a
check is the easiest thing so they made
millions of dollars billions of
dollars well not billions maybe 500
million maybe and you only want 10 what
and you only want 10 that's really not
that much D I'm not greedy you know me I
just want want to [__] go to
Jiu-Jitsu and eat Chinese food until
they put me in the
casket that sounds like a good [__]
life I give a [__] [__] rain like a
[__] here yesterday I know it's
raining up there yeah it's non [__]
people lost that power not me I got a
generator I didn't [__] around when I
moved here that's the first thing they
told me when I moved here get a
generator dog power goes out when I
moved in this house the power just been
back for three days and what is it like
gas do you have to about go to the gas
station and like fill it up how does it
work you see my wife around here
somewhere I don't know what the no it's
not gasoline it's electric because it's
in the [__] in the board I wait it
can't be an electric one unless it
charges because if the power goes out
how's it gonna work it recharges every
Wednesday by itself it turns off the
power house turns off and the charger
takes it over it's [__] tremendous
that's badass yeah the realtor told this
Jimmy Florentine told me that like
before before you buy that house make
sure you got enough money left over for
a [__] uh a generator I'm happy I did
but that's it you know what's [__]
crazy a we right now we're watching this
podcast next Tuesday that's it Christmas
will be over you [__] will be
out with your little cash card spending
money going to comedy shows walking
around New York City dying to get mugged
you know because next week is big in New
York City from Tuesday on straight to
[__] Monday people banging in the
city for New Years going to look at
[__] wait like it's a good time to Rob
someone is that what you're saying well
I don't know what what am I criminal
[__] uh uh well back then a
forecaster of criminal activities I'm
just
saying like Black Friday I don't know no
it's not Black Friday it's [__] right
Black Friday was in November you no I'm
saying for criminals it's not it's not
oh Black Friday for criminals very very
good I like that little jokey you should
write that down and then don't repeat it
anyway what else happened this week I
didn't do [__] no you know what people
got mad at me why because I I tweeted
something they they there was a In-N-Out
opened in Idaho and people waited eight
hours for
In-N-Out so I tweeted that that was St
and I like all I could think of is like
how would you wait eight an hour hours
for in out in your car not for that
[__] that's what I said I went away
eight hours in the car it better be a
good cut of meat and there better be
[__] hair on there or something
something different that flavors it
eyebrow hair something listen
Lee I want you to how old are you now 35
I want you to because you came up at a
different time when I came up when I was
35 it was a different [__] world and
now right now you're coming up in a
world it's so weird how
everything is a [__]
gimmick and you don't see
it like Lee we had our office what a 100
yards from in and out not even yeah you
know we went to the comy store there was
one on Sunset B I remember during the
pandemic the line I saw in and out was
something you'd see for
Woodstock or [__] lead Zeppelin at
the Garden I I'm not kidding you it went
from Sunset and it went all the way to
that street the big street and then it
went all the way up to Hollywood
Boulevard for a [__] cheeseburger
that's small the fries got HIV and I'm
not gonna tell you that listen it's it's
a it's one of the better burgers out
there yeah the burger is great it's one
of the better burgers out there but
before I left that burger was getting
small it was looking like a White Castle
burger and by now with [__] by nomics
that that that's non-existent I know the
prices went up like a
[__] you
know I just always thought that it was
just a tad
overrated it was always Tad overrated
and that that was my personal opinion
you know I'm not a hamburger guy it's
not like I'm GNA sit here with you and
talk to you about my favorite
cheeseburger you know there's so many
good cheeseburgers there really is
[__] I'll take you to places around
here that the cheeseburgers are
brilliant
brilliant like three or four places that
the cheeseburgers are great do I go
there every day or once a week not at
all tonight's the big one aaria $6.95
for a cheeseburger and they give you a
beer with french fries are you [__]
kidding me and it's not like a [__]
McDonald burger it's a goddamn uh
sirloin with [__] short rib you know
these people ain't just making some walk
in there on a Monday there 10 [__]
Savages that's it there should be 300
[__] Savages in there yeah you've
been telling me about that since you
moved there so people it's like a big
gimmick man like when you look at things
you're like I lived there I was down the
block from there I never got it it it's
like when I think the biggest
disappointment is that hot dog plays on
Le oh yeah yeah pinks it's it's it's
total garbage but for people to get off
a plane to go there it breaks my heart
it breaks did you ever go to
Sonic I went to Sonic in h
Tennessee and maybe I'm getting the
wrong stuff but I remember when it
opened here in Massachusetts I was in
high school and they had to shut it down
because it was the line was going to the
highway and I was so excited to go when
I was driving cross country and I've
been I think two times and each time it
was gross like the desserts and the
drinks I'm sure are great but the food
oh it's I was so excited it's garbage
it's hot
garbage but people you know I still
remember when Boston
Market had lines the one in fortly New
Jersey I drove by it one day I thought
they were giving away free [__] cars
it was superb the line and now look you
go to Boston Market they're trying to
give it away they got a [__] PTY you
know it it life comes and goes you know
it's too [__] confusing sometimes
that's why you go what the [__] happened
you know what Burger I do miss from La
The Habit was pretty good I like the
Habit it wasn't like it wasn't amazing
but for like a fast food sort of it was
like in between because they made it for
you I us to take my daughter to the
Habit because she liked it and they
always had a specialty sandwich and
those were
good their steak sandwich was good and
they chicken Mex grilled chicken was
good too grilled chicken with the
[__] avocado and all that [__] you
know but yeah you know it's just I don't
I saw that I saw that eight hour weight
and
Idaho ain't nothing going on in Idaho so
go wa for eight [__] hours you know
what I'm saying I got nothing against
Idaho they canceled my warrant years ago
so we're cool I I want real quick we got
to switch over now for a word from
better help this episode is brought to
you by better help like I've been
talking to you the holiday season is
great I love I love him to be with some
family but it could bring up some weird
stuff better helps online therapy can
help whether you're having a tough time
with your job relationship family having
a total stranger to talk to help from
time to time they're not going to tell
you your wife what you said about her or
cause drama with your friends it's
totally neutral party who can can help
you work stuff out like I said the
holidays sometimes uh an old Thorn pops
up and it don't pop up till a couple
days before and it lurks for a couple
days after maybe you need to talk better
help is there to get you started you
take a short quiz and what you're
looking for on a therapist and they'll
match up it's totally online they got
therapy through video call phone call or
even message whatever works for you
better help is there switch therapist of
any time if you're happier one at no
additional cause listen in the season of
giving give something to yourself take
care of yourself stop worrying about
everything else stop worrying about
what's going on all over the world
listen do me a favor visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz today D and get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
Diaz contact better help you won't hear
that voice ever again
and now back to the checkin we're back
like
herpes anyway better help is going to
help you out these uh next couple weeks
always
taxing so you know there's no shame in
calling better help so do what you do
I'll help you out a little bit you know
whatever you'll save on tissues that's
it anyway what's up with you Tarzan what
are your plans for the holidays and
[__] uh you know oh it's going to be
a it's going to be a fun week I because
my mom was gone visiting uh my brother
and he he just had a daughter A year ago
so she was gone for Hana we haven't done
Hanukkah yet so we're going to do that
with uh Athena and her kids then we got
new uh Christmas Eve which I Christmas
Eve as a kid was everything for me as a
Jewish guy because I we got invited to a
family front like an Italian house and
like they had someone dressed up at
Santa every year and we got gifts so
Christmas Eve is going to be fun with my
family and then Christmas day will be
you know 6: in the morning I love
Christmas it's so much for especially
for a Jewish Guy Christmas is a it's so
much better than Hanukkah and it's and I
love Hanukkah but especially as a Jewish
kid growing up and you see all the
Christmas [__] that's all I wanted so
like I wake up before the kids
do I gotta be honest with you this
Christmas I'm very [__] excited
that's awesome I've this excited in
Christmas in a long goddamn time and for
tons of reasons like it's
just the last two Christmases haven't
been settled I didn't know the scoop but
in my mind like I would spend those
[__] misery Christmases in LA and um
I couldn't wait to get back here to go
like to your house at 6 I go by [__]
florentines at 8 o'clock and then you
know florentines are going to go to
church at 9: so from there your parents
invite us all for cocktail at 10 there
was G to have be some food you know I I
[__] sat there in LA and dreamed of
those and then I moved here and it's
like it's not like that
anymore people I think the uh my my my
my brother Dan Floren he always has a
little something you know and you go
over it's understood you go over there
from 8 to nine maybe he's got [__]
Cavatelli maybe you know who knows but
it just they felt empty
like than the ones I had in LA and this
summer when I went to
Nashville you know I really got to meet
my nephew and my niece and you know my
other niece like I knew my older niece
but I didn't know the two younger ones
and I'm like man this will be great to
come here for Christmas Mercy you know
so I'm going and I'm gonna have a
[__] great time my brother Mike's
coming up for the week to take care of
the cat he's going to stay here I'm
gonna leave him an ounce of weed you
know leaving the keys and then uh I'll
be back five days I'm only going for
five days I'm GNA try to train jiujitsu
in Nashville I'm gonna try to see my man
at zany I'm gonna try to see jelly roll
and the rest of the time just hang out
with the girls man and then come back
come back here and just prepare for
2024 we got to drop it like it's hot we
got plans for these people we got shck
crack a ling for these [__] you
know
so that's my plan I'm sticking to it cuz
I got no reason to lie you know a lot of
coming up over the holidays I mean I
didn't know this there's three [__]
football games on Christmas Eve is it
really yeah I think there's a game
Christmas
day I haven't even looked they're on
Saturdays now too I just saw that this
weekend the next couple weeks man you
got the end of college football you got
pro basketball you know there's just a
lot of [__] going on so you won't be
bored you know listen when you go to
those family reunions you end up
watching sports anyway oh yeah there
some of the men go in one room the kids
come in you either watching football or
golf or tennis whatever the [__] you
like and
uh that's
it it's very n there's not much going on
for 2024 I got a couple [__] things
I'm going to do in 2024 and part of that
is just to to get to get some action
going brother I've been in Central
Jersey for three years just uh you know
trying to put the pieces together now
I'm ready to
percate I Love
It I gotta plan like
Stan I'm excited to see what happens
dude is how does how is like Mercy feel
about Christmas is still big for her no
she don't believe in Santa
Claus oh she know okay her friends don't
say
nothing right she figured it out she
went to the mom and said knock it off I
ain't writing no letter the [__]
Santa it was very interesting what
happened yesterday with her okay I had
an interesting day with my daughter
yesterday
uh you know we got up like at on Sundays
we up at 7:30 blah blah
blah something happened yesterday she
got sick at church last
week so she didn't want to go to church
this
week so there was really nobody around
on Sunday it was really
weird and I was with here till 10: 10:30
I had breakfast with them we were
talking bullshitting and then I went to
Jiu-Jitsu and then I came back and I go
what's going on they was setting up
rooms up upstairs cuz my daughter
switched
rooms and they were finishing up that
and then my wife came down and it was
230 and I'm sitting here watching
football I went over to jimmies oh no I
went over to jimmies and I watched the
Dolphins for a little while it wasn't
even a [__] game you know right
playing the [__] Jets and then I came
back and I'm like girls what do you guys
want to do and my wife's like I don't
know there's not much going on I mean it
was raining already you know it was
starting to rain and one of the moms had
contacted me and said you guys want to
go out to dinner and I go yeah but as we
leaving we go yeah she goes oh by the
way my daughter's not coming I don't
want to take Mercy to sit with four
adults you know what I'm saying so I go
right leave it back here with me when
mercy came down she goes Dad no she goes
and my wife told her she had been in the
house so [__] long and I've been
telling my wife since we moved here my
daughter's not that kid you think she's
a [__] terot bread she needs a little
action TV and the computer of her it
doesn't cut it and she doesn't need to
do much she don't need to do much she
just needs
to so out the house do she came down my
wife told her what was going on and and
mercy goes so what am I gonna do and
just broke down she just had tears in
her eyes and she just came over and gave
me a hug and I you want to get the hell
out of here don't you she goes yeah I
have to get out of here and I go go get
go get your jacket on you know and I I
didn't care about the Dallas game I
wasn't even watching that piece of [__]
game I got in the car as I was getting
in the car I put her favorite music on
that little girl that performed at the
Garden Olivia Rodrigo right okay I typed
it into my phone when she wasn't
watching in my apple and then I got in
the car started it and plugged it in and
that song came on that she likeed and
she [__] you know she smiled and then
I took her on a ride for like 25 minutes
and all those songs came on like the
whole album she likes it was on loud I
didn't say a [__] word though I just
let her process because that's what she
needed to do it's like her dad I gotta
get the [__] out of here in the morning
I'm the type of guy who get up and write
[__] and prepare for the day and what am
I going to do this week but you know
what Tu a sheep [__] sucker it's time to
try out what you believe in you got to
get out of here even if it's to go
around the corner and make a phone call
I I I when I call you I I'm not home I'm
gone already I'm going I'm GNA do
something but I gotta get out of the
house even though I don't have to till
10: it's 9:15 I'm calling you I gotta
get out of the house I'm out of the
house I got the fruit in me I got two
eggs Sunnyside Up and avocado toast bing
boom get that Cuban out of the room you
know what I'm saying and and you could
just and you could just tell that's what
she needed like you guys didn't even go
anywhere you just were driving went for
a ride we going to go get ice cream she
didn't want to we just kept listening to
music and what did we go do oh we ended
up going to barondes & Nobles and I
don't like that barondes & Nobles freeo
because they're the ones that told me I
couldn't do the book signing there so I
was making a right turn if you know
anything about me I'm like I don't even
know why I'm [__] coming in here I
even thought about just giving my
daughter 20 bucks and go go get what you
need to get whatever the [__] it is and
come back because I don't want to step
foot in there but I didn't want to make
no problem so I walked in there with her
and I went in there and I even got more
[__] annoyed because the guy one guy
was watching me like I was a shoplifter
you know because I didn't look the best
I had a hooded sweatshirt on sweatpants
I don't give a [__] it's coming down out
here I'm gonna dress up to go to Barnes
& Noble and look at you like that that's
crazy he did this little [__] dude
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say his ra
racial perpetuation
he was looking at he was eyeballing me
like I was a shoplift and came up to me
do I need any help do I look like I need
any [__] help [__] Tucker I'm
standing three feet from my daughter in
the kids section of [__] Harry Potter
whatever the [__] she got some book by
Tim Burton or something I don't know Tim
Burton wrote a movie he's gonna direct
the movie you know me I just yes him at
that and next you know I'm dropping the
small 20 and my daughter's smart because
she actually walks up to the counter
like she's faking the money like she's
got it in like she's going to take it
out and and then we get to the cter I'm
like you know I'm not going to [__]
outd it here what am I going to do I
just take the money out and pay for it
she always like goes like she makees she
has that that little limp hand you know
little
[Laughter]
G the limp hand did you teach her this
or did you just just something that was
natural but then as I'm paying for the
[__] book I turn around and there's a
book of [__] biographies and comedy
and [__] my book was not on the [__]
table [__] and I'm like these
[__] and I wasn't even gonna
ask him where it was it didn't even
matter to me didn't even matter to me I
don't even want to do business with
those [__] anymore anyway I gotta
break will cre and drop some knowledge
on you from DraftKings give me a minute
hey where you guys been Uncle Joey here
to talk to you about DraftKings let me
tell you something this is the week the
next two weeks is one to throw down you
got basketball you got football all day
College you got what else you got you
got hockey you got everything
everybody's doing something so do me a
favor but what's hot right now is the
NBA this week new customers can score
150 instantly in bonus bets just for
betting five bucks who's better than you
and who's better than Uncle Joey for
turning you on nobody DraftKings that to
so get the party started right now
download the draftking Sportsbook app
and use code Joey new customers can get
150 instantly in bonus bets just for
betting $5 on basketball you know what
that happens only on draftking
Sportsbook when you use code Joey the
crown is yours now if you got a gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net and New York
call
8778 Hope New York and text Hope New
York that's 467 369 in Connecticut help
is available 8887895118
150 instantly in bonus bets all right
merry Christmas jingle jingle back to
the show we're back Jack
anyway so that's it brother that's my
[__] story and I'm sticking to it I
had good weeks I got some plans for
2024 I don't even want to tell you Lee
I'm excited you always have good plans
I'm excited because I gotta do
something I gotta do something
even something small I I got to do
something I got to put something I'm
starting a book in
January and I really thought about the
conversation we had the other night it
really helped me my conversations with
you on this podcast and off the podcast
are really helping me write this book
because I'm looking at efficiencies that
you had I have and other young Comics
have I have a lot of young comics on
patreon and they ask me questions and
it's frustration
everybody wants to know how to get to
the next level and you and I had a
conversation the other
day I don't even know if you remember
and I was telling you that I'm goingon
to write a a chapter about the things I
did
wrong right the things I did wrong and I
[__] wrote one that was tremendous
and it was very hard for me and it was
people always ask me like on the side
like I was talking to a young comic the
other day like at a french fry place I
was there with my daughter I don't I
don't even know it was a french fried
Place wasn't a French Fred
place this was when we went to the city
for
the and the kid goes you know do you
have any advice for a young comic and I
go listen I've been thinking about this
for a long
time not taping
myself not listening to
myself not watching my
videos
I'm G make confession to you Lee out of
all the churches we did I saw bits and
pieces on
YouTube if you thought I sat there
through a podcast and watched
it never watched it the last person I
want to see is me you know what I'm
saying couldn't agree more
so what are you saying about myself I'm
just
teing but I think one of the biggest
mistakes I made and not being serious
about it
is I know everybody's broke I'm not
expecting you to buy a [__] high-end
camera and these [__] uh phones are
600 bucks and you drop it with a [__]
whatever you know they now you got to
deliver pizza for another year to get
another phone or you gotta borrow a
small nickel from Dad you gotta hear
that of your beat you know all you got
to do is tape your sets just make it a
habit to tape your sets whether they're
five minutes 15 minutes tape your
[__] sets it's something I didn't do
and if I could do it all over again from
1991 I would have done them all Joey why
didn't you do it because I was so
insecure about myself I didn't want to
see myself on tape I've never watched a
full special of mine on tape I'll tell
you what I have watched because I could
as I was doing it I could feel it and
that was the Comedy Central things I did
forari besides that I don't watch any of
that [__] at all at all but it was such
a mistake for me and it's such a mistake
for a young comic and you're going to go
Joey but I'm just getting started
because I want you to build healthy
habits now I want you to know that at
home I don't want listen I don't give a
[__] about your sexual preferences I
don't give a [__] about your drug
addictions I don't give a [__] of you
stay out those six doing Molly and
jumping up and down I will tell you what
I want from you as a young comic and is
the first thing you do when you go home
is wash your hands jump in the shower
eat a pie Mom's Apple Pie whatever the
[__] your ritual is but before you hit
that sack I want you to listen to that
[__] tape make two notes just two
notes not negative positive for right
now I don't want you to go to better
upset and then listen to it again in the
morning and make your notes and right
there in the morning when you're eating
your cial make your plans for the next
night what am I going to do different
and not even a plan I just want you to
make a note and then come back at 5:
from work or whatever the [__] you're
doing and then execute that plan for
tonight or the next show whatever the
[__] that may
be that was my
mistake because you never recorded right
like even later on when you had like the
phone no when we met you said to me one
night you want me to record your [__]
set on the way down to aine and next
thing know was a number one [__]
download you know what I'm saying I know
that's [__] crazy that you never did
I
recorded I never because of my
appearance and I was so
insecure that's why I don't like [__]
specials too much I want to listen to
you for me stand up I if I listen to
myself more I would have been so much
betterly it's amazing you were as good
as you were and like never listening to
it you just had that like you just have
a great memory I think because I hated
my
voice and I hated what I looked like
like I didn't want to see me on
stage but there was one thing I did
believe in and what I felt like on that
stage and I'll tell you I walked off
that stage many a night going I wish I
would have tap
that because I wanted to hear what my
heart sounds
like when I was on
stage I wanted to hear
I love hearing a glass get set I love
those I came up on the Richard PRI
albums and the red fox albums and I
could feel the heart coming through the
speakers whether I had earphones on or
we were at one of my friends's house the
special or satino one of them and we
were listening to I love listening to
the
laughter and it was real it was a small
Club it wasn't an arena nobody was doing
Arenas nobody was doing comedy clubs
there was maybe a buck 20 in there Buck
50 and you heard it differently and I
always wanted to sound that way but I
knew no matter what I did it would never
sound that
way but I learned listening to the Beats
I'm listening to beats I'm listening to
you know a beat is when somebody stops
and I'm listening to all these little
things but what I'm really listening to
is his heart that's what I could hear I
can't see it he's a fake he's got a
bunch of tattoos he's got a weird head
do he's got a scarf on I don't want to
see that I want to hear it somewhere
along the line people wanted to see tape
you know and that's where I think it's
I'm I'm an old man I want to hear it
even though I can't hear but I want to
hear
it I I mean we've talked forever about
how much I I love albums but
it's how do you think like how how did
you how did you write if you weren't
listening to you just remembered like
the little changes you would make
yes yes I A lot of times I would oh bro
one of the running
jokes with uh these [__] guys you
know and they'll bring it up to them the
Rogan the AR
is Joey did you write that
down Joey write that down that was like
you write that down you know what's he
doing that's a f you know and because I
knew I could come up with those once a
night I could pop those out of my ass
you know I always knew I didn't know if
I was gonna kill but I knew I had one
line in me that wasn't on the dialogue
that I could pop so and now I regret all
that I threw away hours of material
because I didn't bring it home at night
listen to it and write it
down if I was me and you could be
driving and it happened I'm not making
this up you and I could be driving the
car driving to Irvine Brer Oxnard
whatever the [__] it
was we go over something we talk about
this and you go oh say that joke from
the ice
house and I would get in there practice
the joke in my head not in front of a
mirror like I practice it in my [__]
head and then you get there you have a
great set and you come off and and
you're like Joey that was a really good
set I'm like [__] you I didn't say that
[__] joke oh yeah that one joke was
what I worked on all [__]
week that's the only thing I wanted to
work I just did a complete different set
and the thing that got me to most was
that I didn't do that one [__] joke
you were there a thousand times when I
got off the stage and I go like [__] and
you go like what happened and I'm like I
didn't try to joke meanwhile they're
howling right they had a great [__]
time I didn't give a [__] I didn't try
that [__]
joke that would go on for six
nights was it just you were just in the
moment yeah and then I would go home
then I would try it and I now now I got
a reaction now where am I going with
this [__] beginning right uh we had
this discussion last
week I don't like I like remember the
joke we were talking about right IED
like huh you tried it now you called me
that night you went crazy you tried it
twice it worked you called me going
crazy about what that it worked or what
was the main
concern about where to go from
there it's the same thing I forgot that
joke we look at things so [__]
differently like we people have no idea
how pissed you get as a comic when
they're telling you that was a great set
and you're like [__] I had
something with my sleeve that was going
to make your eyeballs pop out I wish I'd
go back up there and do it but I can't
you know it's just that anyway to get
back to the story I
wish I would have
uh written my got home at night listen
to my tape I really used to get home at
night and I gotta be honest with you no
matter how [__] up I was I always
remembered to go to my notebook write
down how I
did honestly what joke I wanted to try
if I had somebody with me I only put the
parameters and I go back the next
morning but if I was
alone that's when I go through my
process I get pissed off I get a [__]
line of coke and a drink of beer and you
know let me write this over again then
I'd write it over again and that went on
till 6: in the morning it was an excuse
to snort the
coke right but it just I like there are
sometimes I do remember things but
there's a lot of times I'll go back to
listen I don't listen to every set by
any stretch of the imagination but when
I do listen I'm like oh [__] I forgot I
said that so I was thinking about that
when you said like oh you threw away so
much so you definitely threw
away hours
hours but I knew I could I knew I could
write more it's like a coke dealer I
knew I could sell more coke it didn't
matter what I was spending I knew I
could I always knew that I could pop up
something especially when you get on
stage every night when once you get into
that Rhythm you start popping [__] every
two nights then it's every night that
you get off stage and you go I can't
believe I [__] said
that you know and the joke that I think
about the most just to let people know
is when I do AR's Storyteller show when
we beat up the
nun like four jokes in that thing that
were nowhere on the
agenda the when I said I don't like milk
but I like milkshakes
that that was not on the agenda when I
talked about the Puerto Rican kids the
uh whatever Brothers hitting them and I
go they look like Roberto Clemente
[__] came out right there these
are the things that will come out of you
once you get on stage a lot and [__]
you
know that's it that's all I got to say
on that I love talk this [__] and I
could talk it for hours about different
and then you see it in another Comics
I've been on you know I've been on stage
with everybody and I they've gotten off
stage and hey how' you do man I had this
joke I wanted to say [__] I
forgot the wording on and and these are
like top guys you know like they're in
the game a few years so hey if the video
is lagging it's because the Chinese
balloon is in the neighborhood so you
know don't worry about nothing the
[__] uh internet is still Tip Top M
goo but shit's happening we've had bad
weather here
trees got knocked down so but the heart
and soul is still there you get you
still get the voice Like a Man on Fire
you get the guy's voice I caught the
last 20 minutes of that the other night
Jesus Christ I hadn't seen in about a
year it's from the part where he makes
the dude shoot himself the Puerto Rican
dude that was married to Jennifer Lopez
from there on he on a [__] rampage
and I hadn't seen that in a while godamn
I've been catching some [__] killer
movies lately by mistake the way I like
to catch him not planned you just turn
the TV on they're coming in like 10
minutes [__] tremendous movies lately
and I've still been going to bed early F
you know but I love watching like uh I
saw a Man on Fire I saw the getaway was
on the other night I caught the last
hour of
that uh you know a good week with Steve
McQueen maybe the end of a Charles
Bronson movie they've been playing a
movie from 84 from Charles Bronson it's
a good movie not really it's not one of
my favorites a little bit too violent
for me but I caught the [__]
beginning of that the other day till he
took the he threw the guy off the
balcony with a [__] fire hydrant
tremendous you can't write that [__] in
the script you know what I'm saying and
it doesn't bother you to go in like with
like an hour left I can't watch
movies at this point I could rewrite the
[__] movie I've seen it so many times
my point is that I haven't seen it a
long time right so when I told you I
watched Scarface everybody saw Scarface
I saw it 50 times when it came out when
I had didn't have it on for 20 [__]
years you know the other night it was
coming out oh Netflix had it I go let me
turn this on and see what it looks like
it was [__] raw still raw so I like
doing that from time to time nothing new
is coming out it's like you you're
planning to go see no [__] movie the
next two weeks there's really nothing
there's no Christmas movie I think I
think she's going to see Willie Wonka
how many times you're going to make a
wiie Wonka [__] movie if you're not
watching the original Wily Wonka what
what do you doing I talked to her about
I said listen the original willly W is
the [__] Mac Daddy of Mac daddies but
yeah she likes Burton and this guy and
that guy what do you want from me I'm
trying my best just to be a dad smoke
dope and keep the lights on you know
what I'm
saying that's all
you
it's sad that there are no movies coming
out on Christmas because that's what
that's what I was thinking of doing too
and I just looked and there's nothing
nothing you know I always thought maybe
making an investment in like a [__]
movie theater an old one and get movies
10 people told me you're gonna lose your
shirt because what you got to pay to
bring those movies in is [__] hella
high water so what are you gonna charge
$22 you got to charge more in the movie
theater because you have a smaller movie
theater he AMC got a parking lot I'm
talking about getting like a a 98 cater
and showing Charles Bronson weekend
Bruce Lee weekend Lee sayat weekend
bringing Comics during the
week and you think and that would be
expensive I thought that's the whole
reason they show had old movies at movie
theaters because it was cheaper [__]
Q&A about the movies reach shome
everybody join in that's a Tuesday night
club you know what I'm saying maybe
Wednesday play poker and have sucky
[__] in the basement for some people
in the community you know what I'm
saying get the priest in there getting
the party started and
[__] sucky [__] for the
community I went to the heart do eat
town okay and go to his heart doctor
like it's a beautiful building the
neighborhood is great but there's a
little Alleyway and at the end of the
alleyway there's a little light that
just blinks and says massage
I've been to this doctor six times in
three years for checkup blood work and
every time I go I park the car close to
it just to see if anybody comes out of
there or whatever it's open all the time
so finally this week I went to the when
I went that last time last week I walked
in as soon as the doctor walked in I
looked at him I go Dr I let me ask you a
question you ever go to that massage and
let somebody tickle your [__] with a
f dog he just froze up this dude
nobody's ever talked to him like that he
closed the door and he goes no and he
goes but I have thought about it
so holy [__] you asked your doctor
then you gotta ask him you got to blow
him out of his [__] whistle you don't
let him know where you stand if not he
thinks you'll an oy do like everybody
else oh my God I think he might like
Okie do I don't think he wants people to
ask oh my God what would you have done
if he said
yes what what would you have done to me
he says oh yeah I go there every Friday
well give me the code Give me the give
me the 10% off card give me the
referral I don't want to touch nobody I
don't want to kiss nobody but if
somebody wants to blow how my ass with a
straw I'm at that age I enjoy things
like that you know what I'm saying I
don't want to see you're naked I don't
want to touch it I don't want to talk to
you I don't want you but if you want to
tickle my [__] with a feather for 25
minutes for the small 50 I'm
in how how did you find out you like
that what happened how did you find out
you liked getting your [__] tickled
with a feather who you oh when I was
like 20 I bumped into a chick that was a
pilgrim and the party
[Music]
started holy
[__] are you gonna do you do you talk
like this in front of your in-laws do
you have like with your nieces and
nephews do you [__] with them a little
bit um the the ones in Tennessee you
know they're Bible beaters I love them
but I can't talk like this and that's my
nieces I can't talk crazy Mercy could
talk a little crazy now she gets it
listen Urban this neighborhood talks
crazy so I don't want to think I'm a
[__] choir boy that's the farthest
thing I am so uh yeah if F around her
friends I go off from time to time
I love it they must love you and I I've
seen them with you I went off last night
my favorite restaurant because just
[__] every time I go in there there's
like three waiters that are sweethearts
but they always want to talk and if
there's music on and the TV on and the
sh the dining room is back I can't
[__] hear you you could talk all you
want and last night this guy wanted to
talk about Memphis you know I got you
know smoking is after Jiu-Jitsu I think
I ate a mushroom cap that looked like my
toenail I swear to God this mushroom cap
looked just my fungi told on the right
foot so I was on fire I wasn't planning
on going to the restaurant by no means
but my wife my daughter finally goes dad
I want to go eat something after we went
for a long ride so we went to meet the
girls right so he came over you know
what are you doing for the holidays
we're going to Nashville all very nice
you know I'm going to Memphis and you
been to Memphis what are the people like
and I go listen what are you talking to
me for ask my wife she's from Tennessee
I don't know
nothing and then you know I was having
like three conversations at once I'm in
this [__] corner I got Christmas
music over my head [__] I'm trying to
watch the [__] game I got the over in
the Dallas game it don't look like it's
coming in I I don't know what game like
and this guy wants to talk to me about
[__] Memphis and the whole time I
can't hear so finally at the end I go
can I talk to you for a second I
here come here you want to give me a
[__] ear beat and I don't mind I like
everybody talking but I want you to
listen to the music and all I'm deaf
when you come over to me sometimes I go
don't I have a [__] look on my face
I
have rard when I when I don't know
what's going on and you come over and
I'm thinking about some comp I'm
thinking about what I'm gonna eat dinner
this guy's asked me about M and finally
I I was like guy when I come in here
talk to me but if there's music and [__]
it's hello and goodbye I can't hear you
you want to come in here you want
directions to Memphis we would die to
laugh I don't know how to get to
Memphis I'm [__]
deaf especially when there's a lot of
[__] going on I'm not gonna [__] hear
you I'm not gonna hear
you would you like kind of what's that I
said would you like kind of in certain
situations
right like I went to phys therapy the
other day I almost broke my ankle just
to get out of there there was a lady 400
lb all she talking about was a bad knee
and how she can't you know stop you're
killing me here get on the bike and
knock it the [__] off and this went on
for hours she got like two people over
there well let me tell you what happened
I'm like come on lady get up enough with
this your knee hurts because you sit on
the couch eating timans all day watching
[__] game
shows get up get on the [__] bike
come on knock it off she gave him a 20
minute speech you know what she's going
to do oh they were talking about how to
[__] break to somebody's internet I
need this I need this I'm a convicted
felon that I no they they weren't
[__] uh you know internet's they were
saying how people are breaking into the
internet but this went on for 30 minutes
we didn't come here to talk about the
interneto let's go get on the [__]
bike give her a roller skate something
you know what I'm saying
I love when that happens I love watching
you I'm surprised you lasted 30 minutes
what's that I'm surprised you lasted 30
minutes before you said something about
it you
know I'm becoming a [__] Christian as
of short you know what I'm
saying can I ask you something no not
really is Catholicism part of
Christianity cuz I have people who talk
I have no
idea listen I don't know nothing I know
Jesus went out on Thursday they stabbed
he came back on Sunday he died for his
sins I know Adam and Eve ate the [__]
Apple so we don't have to we don't have
to [__] you know if Adam wouldn't
have bit the apple or
Eve everybody we would lived in Paradise
I know things like that all
right this [__] don't know much about I
know about old school Catholic ISM
without getting the finger in my ass I
was there I lived it I went to a
Catholic grammar school the whole
[__] deal and you know I don't know
how it all me I pray to one God I don't
know what color he is you know we're all
in for a [__] surprise so just shut
the [__] up go to work and say your
prayers and put a dollar in the basket
on Sunday you'll be
fine that's what I'll do I love it Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas to you and
your family brother we'll talk the next
couple days and we'll keep you guys
posted on Christmas or what the [__]
we're going to do but for right now we
love you thank you for letting us come
into your home every Tuesday or your car
or your [__] whatever your ear pods
and thank you for being there for us the
last
what Lee wake up out of your coma
I'm I was I was listening for the last
four months all right no we've been on
the air together oh yeah to for us for
about 12 years that's crazy yeah and we
got Sur prises for you next year so get
ready [__] up and stay black and now for
a word from my
[Music]
sponsors the checkin is brought to you
by liquid I V I know you Savages are out
there parting like unbelievable when you
need to recover fast turn to liquid IV
listen you're jumping up and down it's
Christmas you're drinking eggnog with
sinka juice in it you got this you got
this you need to stay hydrated liquid IV
gets you hydrated two times faster than
water alone and it even comes in a
sugar-free let me tell you something
they launched three new flavors the
white peach tremendous the green grap
out of this world the lemon lime it's
like Gatorade and heat and all three of
them will set you on fire after a long
night of jumping up and down and doing
other things you know what I'm saying
I've been there but I'm not there
anymore now I drink liquid IV keeps me
alive in the morning you understand me
after a cup of coffee I drink a little
liquid IV a white peach I put that thing
in it to help me out and boom no gluten
soy dairy or GMOs and no artificial
sweeteners either I don't even know what
GMOs are sugar is replaced with an amino
acid alose blend which has the same
taste and texture of table sugar it's
tremendous try the white peach it'll put
you in a different dimension you
understand me grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier in bulk nationwide
at Costco tremendous they got a bunch of
flavors they even got combo packs now so
you can try a bunch of different combo
packs or get 20 % off when you go direct
to liquid
i.com use code Joey listen Uncle Joey's
going to save you 20% start the 2024
with liquid IV you're going to love it
I'm going to give you 20% off anything
you order when you shop for better
hydration today using promo code Joey
Joe y liquid
i.com that's liquid
i.com the checkin is also brought to you
by
Factor listen if you're trying to eat
bed in 2024 make it easy on yourself
with factor factor is America's number
one ready to eat meal delivery service
that sends Chef prepared dietician
approved meals right to your door they
take two minutes to prepare to prepare
you just heat them up in the microwave
on a skillet and you're all set Tip Top
mooo no waiting in line the grocery
store
no chopping prepping or cleaning up just
an awesome meal right there when you
want them the thing I like about this
most is listen half of us on the go
we're trying to eat healthy this is
where Factor comes in they got 35 meal
options to choose from every week so
you'll have much more variety they come
vegan vegetarian protein plus calorie
smart meals and you'll never skimp on
Flavor right now head to factor
meals.com
Diaz 50 that's D50 go to factor
meals.com and pressing code ds50 you
ready for this I'm Gonna Get You 50% off
who's better than Factor meals nobody
that's
diaz5 atfa factor meals.com
diaz5 to get your 50% off all right it's
the holidays enjoy